winter months are no joke when it comes
to your skin dryness redness how do we
keep it looking fresh well here to help
is owner and Lead esthetician from the
lab Alexandra Sherman welcome thank you
for having me first of all your skin
obviously looks amazing and now you're
from Miami originally you come to Las
Vegas what happened to your skin uh just
completely depleted dry and dehydrated
that's what you get for living in a
desert yeah put on top of that the
winter months what do we need to keep
our skin fresh and glowing during these
months well proper hydration nourishment
and also making sure that you're getting
the right exfoliation whether it's a
chemical or manual exfoliation just
really being the skin for any good
active products afterwards is so
important so we we exfoliate we prep and
then the products now I have a medicine
cabinet filled with products and I'm
hoping they all work but what are some
of your top go-to's when it comes to
Winter skin in terms of Brands I love
biology crochet I mean
there's European Brands like MBR
so just so many different options it
really just depends some things some
companies do like anti-aging better some
do a lot more nourishment so it really
just depends on the person I recommend
seeing a good esthetician that's going
to make sure you're getting what's right
for your skin now one thing I always
hear about and I'm not sure if these are
one of the products hyaluronic acid is
that something that will really help
living here in the desert absolutely I
mean hyaluronic acid is not only an
important ingredient but it's also a
carrier for other active ingredients so
it's going to help products penetrate
deeper into the skin and when you are
malnourished or dehydrated having that
as a carrier is just going to make it
more active and penetrate deeper another
item that I hear especially for
anti-aging can you tell us a little bit
about retinol and how that helps yeah so
retinol can be drying it's not that it's
bad for the skin but it needs to be used
appropriately so that's where having a
good professional to guide you how to
use retinol or vitamin A Products in
different forms can be best for making
healthy skin or helping regenerate the
skin cells now tell us about the lab
because it sounds like the place to go
if you want your skin looking plump and
fresh where are you guys located what
kind of services do you offer so we're
in Southwest Vegas we're off the corner
of Russell and Durango everything we do
is hyper customized so no two facials
will ever be the same
um you know we you're not going to do
what your girlfriend is doing because
you're going to have very different skin
we'll do a thorough skin analysis and
judge your service accordingly just
based on time if we can get our skin
looking like hers we are happy people
thank you so much for driving us it was
a pleasure Scandal I'll send it over to
you